we'll hear from jamie secor more about
uh
quantum coin flipping thank you and i'd
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me
uh so welcome everyone to part three of
four of coin flipping morning
um so i'm going to be talking about some
work without your x 11 10 shell
at the university of waterloo and uh
some quantum and classical coin flipping
protocols based on big commitment and
their point games
okay uh so this is a bit of a mouthful
basically we're going to have fun with
crypto stps okay
so we saw some stps this morning and
we're going to have some more fun
okay so we heard this morning from
udanis for weak coin flipping
okay so just a quick recap we have
analysis bob
they're going to communicate with some
communication protocol and they're going
to output some general
uniformly random bit generated by the
protocol
and we coin flipping uh we adopt this
notion of security
where alice wants outcome 0 and bob
one's outcome one so you could think of
a notion of a winner and a loser
and as we've seen this morning we have
good weak one flipping protocols we can
make these both arbitrarily close to one
half
and this talk is going to be a little
bit more concerned about strong coin
flipping
so a strong coin flipping protocol is
still a coin flipping protocol
but we have a stronger notion of
security in this sense
namely we want to bound all four of the
cheating probabilities
so alice could cheat towards zero but
she may also want to cheat towards one
bob could want zero or he could also
want one
okay uh so it's the same kind of
protocol just a different notion of
security
and we know optimal bounds for these as
well uh so ktev's lower bound shows that
the product
of the two chain probabilities is at
least one half
these quantities are at least one half
so the trivial lower bound would be one
quarter so this is a nice constant lower
bound
uh this was also shown by katowski and
watchers in 2007
using the formalism of quantum
strategies and i guess we'll hear
more after this talk another proof
uh so notice this doesn't apply to weak
coin flipping because
here they want the same outcome okay
um and we can show that this is tight
or arbitrarily tight uh shown by showing
caranitas
uh we can have protocols that make all
four of these chain probabilities
of charlie close to one or two notice
this guarantees at least one over two
so there's this constant lower bound
but these optimal protocols are based on
weak coin flipping
so we understand these optimal protocols
for strong coin flipping
but as much as we understand them for
weak on flipping
so what i'll be talking about in this
talk is looking at a simple class
of strong coin flipping protocols or
just coin flipping protocols
uh and we'll look at their security
and they'll be more simple and we'll be
will be uh focused on how to prove their
security
okay so first i want to show you a bad
coin flipping protocol
and then we'll see how to fix it
so alice is going to choose a uniformly
at random
and send it over to bob bob is going to
choose b uniformly at random
and send it to alice and they're going
to output the xor the two bits
okay so we see they agree on the same
bit and it's
uniformly random but the problem
is that bob can cheat arbitrarily so he
doesn't have to choose b
before seeing a he can use it after so
he can
basically choose the outcome of the
protocol
analyst cannot cheat at all okay
so this is a bad protocol and we want to
look at how to fix this
and the problem was that alice was
sending too much information too fast
and bob was sending all of his
information later in the protocol
so we want a way to kind of balance
these two this transfer of information
okay so we're going to do this with
quantum states
so alice is going to choose a in
superposition okay so alice is still
going to have an a and bob's still going
to have a b
but we're going to have them sending
information to each other in some
quantum way
so ctrl dot a she's going to create this
state here okay so x is an n bit string
and it's going to be weighted in some
way according to a probability vector
alpha a
so her choice of states the parameters
defining them
is alpha 0 and alpha 1.
and for different choices of alpha
she'll we'll see that we'll be
slowly leaking information about a to
bob
at different rates for different values
of alpha
so all together she's going to create
this state down here
so she has two copies of a one for
herself and one for bob
and then she has some way to send some
messages before she reveals a
bob is going to do the same thing bob is
going to create b in superposition and
according to two probability vectors
create some kind of state to reveal his
information about b
um so we can assume he just creates this
big state down here
so the last thing i'll say is that this
entire protocol is defined by four
probability vectors
alpha zero alpha one beta zero and beta
one
and the goal here is we wanna choose
these four probability vectors
in a way to minimize the fortune
probabilities
okay moreover find a way to
study and calculate what these
probabilities are when you are given a
protocol
are there any questions about the
definition of the protocol
yeah so i don't know how messages are
exchanged it seems like you define
initial states
so yeah sorry sorry so this is the
communications protocol
so that was the setup and they're just
going to send information like this
so this is uh so we have three messages
at the beginning so x is a
three-bit string and alice is going to
send x1 over to bob
and bob is going to send y1 so they've
created the states and now they're just
switching registers
l is going to send x2 y2 x3
y3 and now at this point they're ready
to finally reveal what the bits are to
each other
so let's say okay well we're at then the
protocol here's my copy of a
so you can calculate the outcome and
here's a copy of x which you can use
for g detection which i'll say more
about a second
bob says okay that's great uh thanks for
a i'll give you
my copy of b and y for g detection
and what they're going to do now is just
measure
and find out the outcome and whether
they should accept it
so the outcome of the protocol is going
to be the xr of a and b
so alice can perform some measurement to
see whether a and b are equal
but there's also some kind of cheat
detection step if alice
notices alice knows what b is
then this state should collapse into
this state down here
okay so she can perform a measurement to
see if it's in this state
and if she detects that's not in the
state then she'll abort
okay and aborting is bad so whenever
it's aborted there is no outcome
and so bob wants to force some outcome
condition on naughty boarding
i'm a bit confused why where do you get
four whites from
sorry y is just y one my two y three
it's another copy
oh it's just a copy it's not three bits
uh yeah three keep it
um and also bob can also measure the
outcome of the protocol
and since these were in superposition
and everything was nice
he gets the same outcome of the protocol
and he can also
have some kind of cheat detection to
check alice
so this is the protocol and we want to
calculate actually
we want to look at some stps some point
games and have some fun
so here's an stp so we've seen some this
morning and
this is this is basically an sp
the way kate if would formalize it it's
a little bit simpler since we have a
specific protocol we can exploit some of
its structure
um so basically this this right here
encodes the
betas and this is the state bob has at
the beginning of the protocol
and what this stp captures is the state
you could think of the the full state of
the protocol after each of alice's
messages
but the thing is alice who's trying to
force an outcome of zero here she can
only
change the global state of the protocol
by a certain amount because she only has
possession of part of the state but she
can change it in any way she wants
further her private cupids so
we have these variables are the quantum
states under bob's control
and after and we have a constraint for
each round of interaction with alice
so she can change this quantum state a
little bit at the time
and at the end um
bob has some projection which he's going
to apply
and this is going to be the probability
that he accepts an outcome of zero
so this is what he wants to maximize uh
sorry this is what alice wants to
maximize for an outcome of zero and this
is an exact characterization of the
cheating
it's similar it's similar except we
don't have any unitaries
so this structure this protocol is very
simple you create states
and you just switch registers so there's
no unitaries in between messages
and we've gotten rid of the message
space
so i mean but it's the exact same idea
right it's a special place yeah
okay so let's slide this up and have
some fun
what we can do is we can uh write this
down a very simple structure
okay so we have here a bunch of large
matrices called semi-definite matrices
and we can rewrite this in a way such
that we're optimizing
over a polydome okay and these polar
tops are nice so we have a bunch of
non-negative vectors
and these vectors are much smaller than
the size of these matrices
so complex devices is a much simpler
problem
okay in terms of actually solving these
on a computer
this guy up here for a small instance
could take up to three minutes to solve
and this guy takes about 0.08 seconds
so even computationally you start seeing
that this is a much
simpler optimization problem sorry can
you quantify it big and much smaller
so up here so um the size of
sigma all the sigma is the same size and
it's the
bob's entire hilbert space whole quantum
computer
and over here this is just the size of
his first message
received from alice and this is the size
of uh the first three messages and
so on so as quantum
majors these are quantum states yeah and
these are just the diagonals of part of
them
so if we have sigma one as some really
big major
matrix then s1 is
this big so this would be s1
s2 so forth and this end will be the
whole thing
so it's getting quite early yeah that
sounds sensitive
so it's much simpler and up here we
don't have a polytone so we have a lot
more structure
and solving these things or gaining an
understanding it's kind of messy
but it's still a nice problem i didn't
want but a sad face it's still a really
nice problem
but this guy's here he's a lot happier
because we have a polytope and a much
simpler thing and we can do some stuff
with it i mean what you're saying i'm
sorry
you had an sdp upstairs and now you have
np right
and almost lp so this is a feasible
region of a linear program but we still
have some concave function up here
so this is the classical fidelity of two
probability vectors uh
so we're maximizing concave functions so
it's a nice convex optimization problem
but it's much simpler in fact you can
write this fidelity function as
a very small sdp you can characterize it
as a
stp constraint so i'll still consider
this in sdp
but it's a very simplified one
and we can do this for the other fortune
probabilities this is just for alice
forcing zero but we can do it for
forcing one and bob forcing zero one as
well
okay so let's take a step back and see
what we've done and where we want to go
we have to find a quantum protocol and
we have
bob's analysis stps so we can calculate
their cheating
what we can do once we have these stps
or the simplified ones
we can take their duals and we're going
to mash them together
to create some point games
uh so the way i think of it protocols
are cheating strategies
and point games kind of have this
duality nature to them
and this is through some definite
program
okay so here's a point game idea uh
we've seen this this morning but it's
worth seeing a few times
uh we start with two points one at one
zero and zero one
and we're going to associate each to
each point a probability
and then we're going to start moving
these points around in some magical
yet undefined way such that we end up
with a single point
and accumulate all the probability into
a single point
and as we heard this morning uh so i'll
save the way to move them around a
second
but basically the eigenvalues of the
dual variables
are the points that you're sliding
around
okay and the idea is to strip away this
messy
basis information to find out how to
slide the points around
okay uh fortunately for us we've reduced
the problem so much
the basis information is negligible
there's basically no basis information
to worry about
so our point games will end up being
quite simple
um so okay i'll show you what the point
games look like
but here's a bit of notation so we're
going to be moving points around in the
uh xy plane the non-negative ortho
and q here is going to be the associated
probability with this point
so here's a couple of things we're
allowed to do
we have a point and we're allowed to
increase one of the coordinates
either the x coordinate or the y
coordinate and keep the probability
okay uh i just ruined it for x but you
can also do this for the y coordinate
and you can point merge so if you have a
bunch of lines and a bunch of points on
the same line
you're allowed to combine them in a way
such that you accumulate the probability
and the new x coordinate here is just
this weighted arithmetic mean
okay so there's some nice way to bring
them together
uh so here's a very easy point game
we just have two points one zero and
zero one is your probability one half
we're going to raise one of the points
right here
so now it's horizontally uh aligned with
this other one
and then we can merge like i said and
now we have one point
and we're done this is the final point
of the point game and it's right here at
one half
one and we can also
move this guy to the right and then
merge like this so we can merge
vertically as well
and this is the final point of that
point game okay
but we're going to need a little bit
more mass if we want to do these quantum
point games
but not too much more so we'll need the
notion of point splitting
so point splitting you have a single
point and you want to kind of
exploit it into several points either
horizontal or horizontally or vertically
and the way you do this you have some
kind of accumulation probabilities
and they end up being the individual
probabilities of the points that are
split
and you have to have you preserve this
kind of uh weighted harmonic mean
down here so there's a little x i down
here
and that ends up being the points over
here okay
so it looks a little scary but uh the
pictures are a lot nicer so
don't worry about it you won't have to
memorize this by any means
splitting is just the inverse of merging
if you split then merge you'll get some
other thing
conceptually on a picture yes exploding
and bringing it back together but
yeah great
life isn't so kind okay so here's bald
stool
um this is the duel for the reduce
problem
and
what we can do is we can just look at
each constraint
and we can see that each one corresponds
to one of these point moves
so right here so va is a vector
and diag is the diagonal matrix with va
on the
diagonal and this right here you just
take one of the probability vectors
square root each one and then take the
rank one plus semi definite dota product
and if you look at this for a while you
can rewrite this
in terms of this um harmonic mean kind
of thing
so we have that the sum of this guy here
has to be less than or equal to one
and that ends up being a point split
and each thing here corresponds to
something so we have a
sum here and this will correspond to a
point merge
and these inequalities will induce point
raises
and one thing that's nice about the dual
if you're familiar with duality theory
if you're given any satisfying
assignment of these constraints here
this value up here will be be
an upper bound on how much bob can cheat
since this is a minimization problem
so this is a way of upper bounding how
much ball can cheat towards teocom1
so is this because of your special kind
of protocol so in general you can
this only holds for a special kind okay
yes so yes i'll give you the tool you
cannot tell me here is my speaker here
but in general uh do you have anything
to eat
no no so you might have some in general
you'd have a bunch of unitaries
okay so you'd actually have to do all
the stuff you did this morning
so this is just the dual of the polytope
basically so all the basis information
is stripped away
and we can do the same thing for atlas
alice we have a similar constraint down
here
uh corresponds to a point split and we
have some point merges and some point
raises
and we have an upper bound on cheating
once we have this
so we're going to look at these two uh
beasts at the same time
and we're gonna find a point game okay
so the point game it'll take me three
slides to get through it
but it's conceptually not too bad we
start with this guy down here
and we're going to do some point splits
so
we're exploding the points horizontally
and up here
we're raising these points so that
they're vertically aligned with each one
down here okay
so you can already see this will not be
good for optimal weak coin flipping
we're throwing away way too much
information
uh so we've done this now what we do is
we take these four points
and we're going to horizontally point
split them this way
and after we just merge everything until
we get a single point
so we have we have a bunch of points up
here and a bunch of points down here
we're just going to merge them
vertically like this and then we're
going to take the new points merge them
like this
merge and merge okay and then we end up
at a single point right here
so there's two funny things that
happened at the beginning with these
point splittings but after it was just a
matter of bringing everything together
either horizontally or vertically
and why do we care about such a point
game
this point game is useful because we
have these
stp notions carrying through so
right here we looked at the dual of
blockchain towards one and alice gene
towards zero
and this final point since it was
created from a feasible dual solution
it upper bounds the cheating okay
and this just comes from weak duality of
semi-definite programming
but we also have strong duality for
semi-definitive programming which means
that you can actually make these tight
okay so if you're given the
parameters of the point game you can
actually find you can move them around
in such a way that you
actually get this this value here
so this is an exact characterization of
cheating in this sense
let this bounce sweet coin flipping only
because i've only talked about boxing
towards one and al's gene towards zero
okay what we want is a way to use these
point games
to bound all four gene probabilities um
and in general i don't think this is
known if you have some kind of point
game
it only has two coordinates and you can
bring it back to a weak coin flipping
protocol through a series of steps
uh but there's no guarantee on what the
other teaching probabilities will look
like
here since we have a one-to-one
correspondence between the point games
and the protocols
uh what we can do is we can pair point
games we can look at the point games
and if we see how the splits were done
at the beginning
preserve how the splits are done just
kind of in a flipped order
you'll get a new point game and it'll
bound the other two chain probabilities
as well
and what's nice here is that these pair
of point games whenever you go back to
the protocol they go back to the exact
same protocol
okay so the simplified nature of what's
happening here allows us to do this but
in general this is not true
if you take two point games you can't
just take them back to the same protocol
as far as i know anyway okay
so now we have bounding strong flipping
as well
is there a question it seems kind of
like magic here
you're gonna explain more about it so
okay so
the point games and the dual feasible
solutions are pretty much a one-to-one
correspondence
they're they look pretty much the exact
same the magic comes in
from reducing the sps to that specific
form
so once you take complicated stp and get
to something that looks like a linear
program
you pretty much get the point games for
free
okay but we can also look at the
classical counterpart you want to ask me
yeah so if you're saying that this very
simplified sdp
is the same as point games right but
these are the same
games that you kind of also characterize
the
general sdps that should this kind of
say that you don't lose much going from
the general sdp to this very simple
almost linear programming thing
so your question was if you take this
simple point game and you turn it back
into a protocol
you get a restricted class of point
games right
yes this is very restricted yeah
so what's the restriction okay so this
morning
you took weak coin flipping protocols
and you had point games
and you had a one-to-one correspondence
or you go from one to the other and
back this you have a subset of protocols
and a subset of point games
and they're in one to one correspondence
basically you don't have ktk transition
so this is the only one point too many
points or many points to one point
yes but they have to be done in that
particular order that i showed
what is that particular order so there
is point splitting
and then there's playing this way and
then just merging like this
i see so two splits yeah
how many rounds you um well the merging
takes place just like this
so so there's actually
so so there's actually you have to merge
so many points each round so you have to
merge
certain indices and then you have to
merge certain ones merge certain ones
like this
always terminate after only three
mergers or in general
uh it'll always it'll always converge
yeah so you're always
taking you know to the endpoints of to
the n minus one points
and sometimes you have to raise them
such that they're aligned so that you
can merge
but yeah so i guess the number of
mergers
corresponds to the number of uh register
clips or uh the number of merges
corresponds to the number of
dual sdp constraints and that
corresponds to
the the dimension of the messages that
has been revealed up to a certain point
the protocol
which is the lift yeah
uh and we can also look at classical
point games so i said that this reduces
to something that looks like almost an
lp
um so i looked at that a little bit and
was wondering what this polytope was
actually characterizing
and it's characterizing cheating in a
classical protocol
okay and this classical protocol is very
similar to the quantum protocol
except instead of superposition you're
just using uh
probabilities okay instead of creating
this weighted superposition
just sampling probabilistically okay so
basically you're removing this quantum
measurement
which makes the quantum protocol secure
and we can look at the dual lps and we
can also find a classical point game
which is a special case of the quantum
point game okay
and basically what we're just doing is
removing the point splitting at the
beginning
all we're allowed to do is raise raises
emerges
okay so here's a classical point game
that favors cheating alice
okay assume this is an optimal point
game so this is the optimal final point
then we're saying here that bob can only
achieve with so much probability and
alice can cheat towards one
and over here as well this is one
favoring cheating
bob bob can cheat towards one and alice
can only cheat with so much probability
uh so classical protocols are nice they
made this nice picture
but we can actually study the quantum
security using the classical protocols
the first thing is that we have a
classical equivalence as well between
the classical protocols the classical
point games
and what we can show is the classical
point games have large final points
there's no way for a classical point
game to have a final point that's
strictly within this box here
and because of this weak duality strong
duality stuff
this shows that classical coin flipping
protocols are insecure
can you explain why it doesn't go to
half i mean because we have classical
protocols
right where one of the players cannot
chill at all and the other player
cheats perfectly right so yes yes yes
yes this is a good question
so there's actually some kind of magic
that's happening in here with
uh how they're raised so i said the
merges have to take place in a certain
order
so there's some over here there's some
uh
you're only emerging some points at a
time and then sometimes you have to
raise them
because you have these raised point
races
you put on classical protocols
the restriction on the point games the
actual recipe of the point games you
have to follow a particular recipe
uh yeah
does this give anything new for the
classical games
we already knew classical games are
insecure yeah this is just another way
or is there
some additional information between
um yes yes there actually is some
so um i'll get to your in 30 seconds
so we can show that classical coin
flipping protocols are insecure so this
is another proof for this
class but by looking at the classical
security we can show that at most one
party can cheat perfectly
okay and since classical is an upper
bound on the quantum
quantum is the stronger one uh this
holds in the quantum case as well
what do you mean by at most one
particularly if if alice
can uh cheat perfectly to determine the
outcome bob cannot
even if the protocol is like totally
stupid yes yes yes
yeah so it's a bit of a safeguard even
if you choose these protocols in a
really stupid way they both catch you
perfectly
and more surprisingly if you look at
ktev's lower bound
in this setting and you try to saturate
all the constraints
so you want a protocol with cheating
exactly one over root two
you can show that if a quantum protocol
has this
uh property then the cheating in the
quantum case equals the cheating in the
classical case
so you have all four of the cheating
probabilities equal to one or root two
so basically if you have a protocol
where contains bounds saturated the
product equals one-half
you can show that these two
probabilities are also attained in the
classical version of that protocol
and therefore one of them has to go one
long one has to equal one half
did you have a question yeah i'm
confused about the fact that you can't
both cheat for example if i have a
protocol where
um well the alice sends
takes random bit sends it to bob
and bob is supposed to send back
the same bid to alex and what both sends
back to alice
is then taking us the final outcome
and what bob sends back to alex yeah so
ellis picks around a bit since
bob is supposed to send it back and
alice doesn't check whether she's
getting the right one
bob's generating a completely new random
bit not honest for honest box sends bit
back yeah so could fix
the bid to what he wants yeah probably
one cheating alice could also fix
what she said in the beginning and
honest box sends it back so she they can
both cheat was probably one
the cheating is the probability that the
honest player accepts the outcome of the
dishonest player
i can always say zero you can always say
one so yes but in this case both will if
only one sheet they would both agree and
but everyone can cheat
no there's probably not agree if i send
you zero and you're supposed to say
that's my product
that's my protocol description i mean
it's a stupid protocol but
i mean that that there are so that there
are some protocols where only one can
cheat that's clear
but uh so this so there could be
protocols where they both could cheat
perfectly
i'm not ruling out the possibility that
there exist protocols or they can both
keep perfectly what do you remember
i'm just saying in this class of
protocols either quantum or classical
that's not the case
um okay so here's some open questions uh
so i want to find the optimal protocols
within this family i still haven't been
able to do it i've been looking at the
stps but they've been quite difficult
um and we've done some numerical tests
showing that three-fourths is optimal
uh we check four and six round protocols
with large dimension messages
uh we actually checked about 10 to the
16 protocols so
did you actually find it what's the
number that you actually achieved
three-fourths is the best oh sorry i
forgot to mention the three-fourths
protocol of a minus
is within this class okay so we know the
protocol three-fourths and we won't know
if we can do better
um so yeah so we think three-fourths is
better and we can use this equivalence
to point games to prove it if we
better understand what's going on uh can
we use
independent coin games to simplify
things um
i'm not quite sure i don't think so but
maybe and in general
we find point games for strong coin
flipping okay can we kind of find take
two point games and map them back to the
same protocol or some other kind of
magical business
and ultimately what are the optimal
solutions for the sdps which
characterize optical cheating in the
protocol
thank you
um we already know that you can take a
week of flipping protocol uh with vast
epsilon and to turn it into
an optimal uh strong coin fitting
protocol
square one over square root of two plus
six
suppose we take an optimal strong coil
flipping protocol with bias
in can you use it as a black box to
create a weak point
flipping protocol with by a smaller than
p
uh so the question is can you go from
strong coin flipping back to weak coin
flipping
but with better with a better parameter
so
uh as far as i don't know if we can find
improvement in stronghold flipping
it may give us some insight but i don't
think this would automatically reduce to
uh
something like that so think that the
answer is no but i uh
i'm interested in whether you have proof
or no
insights for why you think the answer is
no so um
so when i was starting this i wanted to
find a better stronghold flipper
protocol something that was in between
one over two to three fourths to get
some intuition behind what to do
how to find better record flipping so
right now the best we coin flipping has
cheating uh two-thirds
the best explicit simple explicit
protocol
um but yeah i don't have any general
idea on how to do this okay i think we
should
move on